[Music]
okay everybody i'm
really really excited today because i
get to speak with the already legendary
anna cath card who plays kitty and then
to all the boys
series and there's a new one coming out
called to all the boys always and
forever
anna how are you doing today i'm so good
thank you how are you
i'm doing really good so you know anna
it's really interesting because
it's so cool that you're so successful
at such a young age
and you have a million followers on tick
tock four million on instagram
can you kind of just go into the mindset
of experiencing that like the pros and
cons of having that much
fame already yeah no it's it's crazy i
think it's
a whirlwind because it's happened it's
happened so fast and it was very
unexpected to me
um doing these different projects that
i've done of course i was excited and i
thought people would like it but i never
really expected
this type of fan base and this kind of
thing so it is really exciting and i'm
lucky that i have a family that is so
supportive and that i have friends who
are supportive and that
i can kind of go through these things
and learn as i go so
yeah it's been it's been so exciting on
crazy ride
yeah no that's really good to hear and
that you have such a good support system
which is so important and
i think what's really cool too is one of
the my favorite quotes you had on record
saying was that
in the past you didn't really take
acting lessons but you grew up watching
the disney channel and netflix and kind
of learn from that
i think that's a really encouraging
thing especially because we're all kind
of in quarantine and there isn't really
like
acting classes in person going on so can
you kind of just delve a little more
into that process like how that was
like watching and learning yeah my mom
would always tell me i was watching too
much tv when i was younger
and now i can be like it was just my
research and now that's brought me here
but um it is crazy because i
i never really thought that i could do
this as a career like
i was always a dream of mine when i was
like in elementary school and i was
little
watching tv being that it would be
amazing to be there but
i never even thought it was a
possibility like in my mind it was just
as realistic as like being an astronaut
like i was like uh that's so
far out of reach like it's very a
distant dream and
now that i actually get to do it and
it's crazy and it's still mind blowing
all the time i'll like step back
like that's wild this is actually
something that i am so lucky that i get
to do
and follow this passion that i have so
it's been a really crazy ride
yeah no that's that's really exciting
and i think that's like such an
inspiration to people especially
younger actors to where they start and
how they learn
so it's really cool on your part and
going into this film now this third
installment of the to all the boys
series
kitty to me in the previous films is the
puppet master behind everything i feel
like in the first film of course she
sent out
letters and then she set up her dad with
a neighbor
can we expect in the third film any more
of this puppet mastery behind the scenes
of kitty yeah i mean i think
definitely a little bit and she
definitely likes to keep bringing up
that
peter and laura jean's romances all
because of her
and she wants to make sure laura g knows
that but
something that's kind of exciting that
she has her own little
love interest in her own little
storyline that we've never really seen
kitty in in that light before
she's always focused on other people's
business so that was
that was really fun to play and i think
fans are really gonna enjoy seeing her
have her own
her own little peter in a way so sure
absolutely that's
really exciting here too and uh i have
to ask too because
you guys right you filmed the second
film the third film pretty close
together was that
kind of crazy transition and was that
pretty stressful
it was really crazy we shot them yeah
pretty much back to back i think
something we would always just get
confused of like did that happen in that
one or did that happen
in that one because it all just is is
one big blob in our head
but it was so fun because we had like
the momentum going and we were
we were all on a roll and we were like
we got to come back and do this again in
like just a few weeks
and do it all over so it was it was
really special and it's so crazy that
now
now it's over it's so sad yeah so that's
what's going to ask was that
like a very emotional onset it being the
last film that had that different vibe
to it and
what would you take away the most for
your career from doing these films
yeah getting to work with this cast and
and this director and this crew
was seriously a crazy unforgettable
experience
i they've all kind of become my older
sisters and older brothers in a way and
i've learned so much from them as an
actor but also just as a person and
i've kind of grown up on this set a
little bit which is crazy because
i first booked this role and i just
finished grade eight and now i'm
graduating high school which is so wild
to think about it
it's been thank you that has been all of
those years um
but yeah i think something that's really
cool about this set is it's so
collaborative like if i have an idea
about
something that i think kitty would do or
a line that i want to bring up
i can totally bring it up and people
will listen and people will talk and
it's kind of like a teamwork thing not
just not just doing what it says on the
page and
and that kind of thing so i will
definitely take all the stuff i've
learned from this into all my
future future projects yeah so speaking
of your future projects and career
like would you ever consider going into
writing because i know you
write amazing puns on instagram uh there
was one you had about
the i and this isn't a cornea i thought
that was hysterical
and oh my god yeah and i wonder though
because you also show skills already
like you love photography and i feel
like that would translate to
cinematography or directing
are those kind of fields you'd be
interested in yeah no for sure
um that that's so funny i try i try way
too hard with my captions
also you mentioned this at the start i
don't have four million followers on
instagram
i would have loved to but i have like
two and a half just want to clarify
anyway
you're being humble but continue anyway
i would love i would love to do writing
one day i've
i have so many ideas and i've made like
mood boards for scripts before and i've
written a few things just for fun
and if i ever got a chance to actually
like bring those ideas to life would be
the best so definitely one day hopefully
i can do that
see that's really exciting to hear and i
think people are going to really miss
the character
of kitty and especially your acting in
this film but watching it
i see potential of a spin-off whether it
be a series of kitty or another film
i feel like it's the better call saul to
this would you ever be interested in
doing that
for sure i would totally be down i mean
anything can happen that would be pretty
wild i think
kitty has so many possibilities that her
life could go in so many different ways
and i think she's such a fun character
that now
she'll probably be going to high school
soon and meeting new people and
i can totally see her like head of
student council and
doing all these fun things i think yeah
i think it would be the best to see
where where she goes
yeah i would love that too um but for
now everyone can
take this in while they can this final
film it comes out to all the boys always
and forever on netflix february 12th
everyone make sure to check it out and
also to catch up
on the first two films on netflix if you
haven't watched them and you get to see
anna as
kitty here anna is there anything you
else do like to promote before i let you
go
um no just thank you to everybody who
loves these movies so much
i hope you love the third one as much as
i do
yeah they're gonna they're gonna love it
uh thanks so much anna and i hope to
talk to you in the future
yes thank you